for immediate release
i really hope that means for immediate
release
for the rest of time for any brand see
press releases are ludicrous in this
world
that is giving a demonstration in a
world that is now working the room
it blows my mind in 2009 that people are
sending out press releases
nobody gives a crap so please
corporations
brands do not employ people that write
press releases for you
they absolutely have no impact in
today's world
zero zip zilch please
i'm asking you stop it because what you
have to understand
is that storytelling is the way you
build a brand
and storytelling is not dictating your
story
in a press release storytelling is a
give and take have you ever seen
somebody give a good story
yeah you're right duh it's all
encompassing like that
big fat ass italian uncle who crushes it
every time after a couple of glasses of
chianti that's how your brand
needs to be your brand needs to be a big
fat ass italian
uncle you need to care and you need to
be out there
need to be authentic from the heart not
a cold-minded press release
that means nothing to anybody hold on
the phone's ringing
with lizzy you know oh it's aj so i'm
still good you know
i'm having a baby in seven days i know i
was in an intense video today
anyway storytelling the same reason walt
disney
and vince mcmahon and biggie smalls and
tupac
are the greatest of all time is the same
way that your brand can be as well
when you paint the picture of what your
brand is and the way you do that in
today's world
is you get into the trenches and you
paint that picture a million little
times not just one time and see the
laziness of brands
because they want to send a press
release or put their pr team on it or
spend eight billion dollars on a
commercial run or billboards or tv
because that's traditional
is going to be the downfall of those
brands and the people that are in the
trenches
answering their emails getting involved
in searching their name or
at replies on twitter going into their
facebook fan page and creating
interaction
going to events meetups caring they're
the ones who are going to win
they're telling their story every day
every second on a small level the people
that are looking for the roi
and how many eyeballs are gonna happen
have no idea what's gonna hit them
it's very exciting to me and i just
really hope that i never get another
press release in my inbox tell your
story tell it every day
and tell it from the heart make it
authentic care don't [ __ ]
and you have a business